but to consider the shape of the
organism as such and the inner qua inter
merely of the shape is in fact no longer
to consider organic being for the two
aspects which we're supposed to be
related are posited as merely
indifferent towards each other with the
result that the reflection into self
which constitutes the essence of the
organism is done away with what really
happens here is that the attempted
comparison of inner and outer is
transferred to inorganic nature here the
infinite notion is only the essence
which is concealed within or Falls
without in self consciousness and no
longer as in the organism is objectively
present the relation of inner and outer
has thus still to be considered in its
own proper sphere
paragraph 287 is rather short and unlike
many of the shorter paragraphs is not an
awful lot going on in there so it
doesn't require too much commentary
Hagel is telling us that you know we're
considering the inner and the outer in
their relationship to each other that's
what's been going on throughout these
previous paragraphs and he says to
consider the shape the gestalt and I put
here you stall tooling as well because
that's what we've been talking about so
far to the top then right to to consider
to handle the this exterior the the
outer part of the organic being organism
to consider the shape of the organism as
such and the inner merely of the shape
he says is no longer in fact to consider
organic being we've seen him say this at
a number of points already you know the
cadaver is not the animal the dissection
is not the living organism and we can go
on from there so he says the two aspects
which were supposed to be related are
what positive is merely indifferent to
each other the outer in relation to the
inner the entire outer in relation to
the entire inner they they lose their
connection what what connection are they
losing remember the outer was supposed
to be in some way the expression on the
inner but now we're finding that that's
not holding up and we're starting to
despair of having laws about these so he
says that the reflection in the self
which constitutes the essence of the
organism ends up being done away with we
end up with something that we can
cognize but something that in the act of
cognizant we in effect lose hold of we
substitute something else for it what
he's been calling in these earlier para
rest leading up to this number and in
the paragraphs yet to come he's going to
talk about in terms of specific gravity
and cohesion and certain
Bertie's like that then we're being used
by the science and the philosophy of
science particularly they have condom
that of shelling of his time and it's
not really that interesting to go into
the details about that in part because
what we want to see is well what is
Hagel driving it so he tells us what
what happens here is that the attempted
comparison of inner and outer gets
transferred to inorganic nature we start
to treat these things as if they were
within the same domain as say chemistry
biology reduces to chemistry you might
say or do physics so he says the
infinite notion is only the essence
which is concealed within or it falls
without in self consciousness right it
could be outside and no longer as in the
organisms objectively present so this is
a problem so he says this relationship
of inner and outer it has to be
considered it as its own proper sphere
and that is where you leave Loftus is
paragraph with something yet to come
in the first place that inner aspect of
shape is the simple singularity of an
inorganic thing is specific gravity as a
simple being it can be observed just as
well as the determinants pneus of number
of which alone it is capable or strictly
speaking it can be found by comparing
observations and seams in this way to
give one aspect of the law shape color
hardness toughness and a countless host
of other properties would together
constitute the outer aspect and would
have to get expression to the
determinate pneus of the inner that is
number so that the one would have its
counterpart in the other
here in paragraph 288 we get to see a
little bit of what we might call the
weirdness of Hegel in dealing with
natural sciences raising its head
because he's going to talk in terms of
something that some of us are familiar
with already that is specific gravity or
Spezza be severe literally the specific
weight or having us of something yeah
that's a term that doesn't doesn't
really mean the same thing exactly at
least in its full significance for Hegel
as it does in the present for us where
for example I dread it's this in terms
of home brewing and there were thinking
about it in a somewhat different way so
I don't want people to get too caught up
on the mechanics of this and I want you
to think rather instead of what what is
Hagel actually driving at here and how
might we extend this this discussion
which is going to have to do with
specific gravity and then these other
qualities and then something else you
know cohesiveness how my knees apply in
in other forms today so in this
paragraph he talks about you know
specific gravity I says that it that
inner aspect of shape as the singularity
of inorganic thing is specific gravity
right so we're treating it as the
organism as an inorganic thing and
resigning to us on number so why is this
important well you know this was seen in
the science of Hegel's time as one way
to get a handle on the incredible
variety of life and one way you can
think of specific gravity at least what
the commentators when they're talking
about this like hip elite have to tell
us about this is that they're looking at
the relation
[ __ ] between you know volume and mass
and they're interested in that fur
organisms and there was this notion
which seems completely unworkable you
know when you actually plot it out hey
it was going to say it's completely
unworkable they had somehow we could
associate particular numbers of this
sort with particular organisms and that
really doesn't seem to hold up that was
that was part of the idea that I'm
inhales going to criticize that not just
by saying what are you guys talking
about but I buy it by connecting its up
to other things so he says okay so
you've got that as the inner that's
that's fine right and then he says what
else then what about the outer so he
says she color hardness tough toughness
and a countless host of other properties
it a little bit of irony there because I
don't when's a [ __ ] innumerable and
unmemorable mega crowd of other
properties right we have all these other
things that are characteristic of the
outside of the organism or the thing and
the question that is well how are they
related to specific remedy this number
that we have and he says these we have
to give expression to the determinant
pneus of the inner that is number so
that the one would have its counterpart
in the other there's supposed to be some
sort of correlation between the two of
these and now we have to see well is
there actually such a correlation
now because negativity is understood
here not as a movement of the process
but as a unity brought to rest or as a
simple being for self it appears rather
as that by which the thing resists the
process and inwardly preserves itself as
indifferent towards it but in virtue of
the fact that this simple being for self
is a tranquil indifference towards an
other specific gravity appears as one
property alongside others and with that
all necessary relation of it to this
plurality in other words all conformity
to law ceases specific gravity as this
simple inner does not have the moment of
difference within itself in other words
the difference it has is only
unessential for it is just it's pure
simplicity that it faces all essential
distinction this unessential difference
magnitude must therefore have its
counterpart or other in the other other
aspect that is the plurality of
properties since it is only through this
that it is difference at all if this
plurality itself is concentrated into
the simplicity of the antithesis and
determined say as cohesion so that this
cohesion is a being for self and other
that's just a specific gravity is a pure
being for self then this cohesion is in
the first place pure determinant as
posited in the notion in contrast to
that other determinate miss and the way
of formulating the law would be that
which we considered above in connection
with the relation of sensibility to
irritability in the next place cohesion
qua notion of being for self in other
pneus is further only the abstraction of
the aspect standing over against
specific gravity and as such has no
existence for being for self and other
necessity inorganic would have to
express its being for self is a self
preservation which would secure it from
emerging from the process as a moment of
the product of a product but just this
is contrary to its nature which has no
purpose or universality in it it's
process rather is merely the specific
activity in which it's being for self
that is its specific gravity and suspend
but this specific activity itself in
which its cohesion would exist in its
true notion and the specific quantity of
its specific gravity our notions
completely indifferent towards each
other if the way in which they react to
each other is left out of account and
attention is confined to the idea of
quantity we could perhaps think of the
determination like this that a greater
specific weight as a more intensive
being with itself would resist
involvement in the process more than
would a smaller specific weight but
conversely the freedom of being for self
only proves itself in the ease with
which it enters into relation with
everything and preserves itself in this
multiplicity the set intensity without
extension of relations is an empty
abstraction for extension constitutes
the outer existence of intention but
self preservation of the inorganic in
its relation falls as we have noted
outside of its nature since the
inorganic does not contain within itself
the principle of movement or in other
words because it's being is not absolute
negativity and notion
paragraph 289 might appear a bit
confusing but you have to keep in mind
that what Hagel is actually talking
about here is no longer the organic
being understood as organic being what
we've been going through in much of this
section but now how we might consider an
organic being that has this being for
self in terms of the inorganic nature
that it's you know exterior it is
connected up with and what observation
of nature might want to try to reduce it
to in order to make it amenable to to
law Hagel is going to show us here one
reason why that that sort of dream or
ideal or you might even call it
reductive strategy is going to have to
fail and he's doing it in terms of what
is Weaver mark this beard notion of
specific gravity that is running through
some of what's what's passing for the
philosophy of nature the philosophy of
science the science of nature of the
time and you don't want to get too
caught up in worrying about that but
paying attention to what's actually be a
discussed here he says so negativity and
I don't have negativity on the board in
part because I don't I don't really want
to bring it in at this point but he says
negativity is understood here not as a
movement of the process right not as
organic but as a unity brought to rest
or it as a simple being for some so
we're taking this complex idea of
negativity and Hegel and try to smooth
it out sort of flatten it out here as
something that we can really essentially
make positive that he says it appears is
that by which the thing was just the
process inwardly preserves itself as it
different towards that process so what
is it that remains the same in the
process that's part of what we're
getting at he says in virtue the fact
that this simple being for itself is a
tranquil indifference towards and other
specific gravity appears as one property
along
others so what we've got here we sent
that specific gravity could be
identified in the last paragraph with
the inner and it still remains you know
the inner of the outer right there any
of this whole plurality of properties
what in the last paragraph you call the
whole NASA a number Abal crowd of them
hardness shape color these sorts of
things you know we were thinking about
organic be any you know we could talk
about the color of an animal but really
we're talking about the color of parts
of the animal usually its skin right
we're not talking about everything else
it's got a lot of different colors yeah
that's only animals that are fairly
monochromatic so what we're really
thinking about here is more inorganic
substances and Hagel is going to explore
the relation between these now so he
says simple specific gravity right would
have some sort of relation with these
these other properties if it doesn't
then our notion of law ceases so we want
to have some sort of connection between
them so he says specific gravity does
not have the moment of difference within
itself why the difference it has is only
unessential it's just a number it's pure
simplicity that it faces all essential
distinction he says so what is this
we've already seen this many times
number or magnitude yeah that for Hegel
looks like its scientific looks like
it's amenable to be a trick being turned
into laws but turns out not to be the
basis for laws so he goes identity says
this unessential difference must have
its counterpart or other in the other
aspect the plurality of properties these
stand over against it since it is only
through this that its difference at all
right if this plurality itself is
concentrated into the simplicity of the
antithesis and determined say as
cohesion now cohesion is just a english
transliteration of the German you know
cohesion there if we're trying to
consolidate those into
asian or his angles going to call up the
being for self in on Ernest we've seen
it on previous paragraphs that the s the
externally the outer is in relation to
other this right maybe we have the
possibility of some sort of law
correlation there between specific
gravity and cohesion so is that going to
work he says how was that going to help
he says here we go cohesion is in the
first place pure determinate as positive
in the notion in contrast to that other
determinist in the way of formulating
the law would be that much we considered
above in connection with the relation of
sensibility to irritability maybe we
could connect these up with what we've
been trying to do before irritability it
would be the cohesion you know
resistance the sensibility or
sensitivity would be the specific
gravity now we can ask ourselves how
well did that work we saw it didn't work
we tried to whole bunch of different
ways to make that turn into something
that would in fact provide us with long
hunt we saw that it never really ulid us
anything like necessity it seemed rather
arbitrary why is that well Hagel is
going to give us a little bit of
explanation here he says cohesion quad
emotion of being for self and ugliness
is only the abstraction of the aspect
standing over against specific gravity
yes such has no existence for being
herself another pneus is the process in
which the inorganic would have to
express its being herself as a
self-preservation which would secure it
from emerging from the process as moment
of a product so you know the organic
nature wants to preserve itself sounds
good in terms of cohesion and then angle
says well that just doesn't happen that
way why this is just just this is
contrary to its nature which has no
purpose or universality within it that's
one of the fundamental
this is between inorganic nature and
organic nature Hagel says right organic
nature actually has purposiveness
teleology your organic nature doesn't
have that it can be brought into a
teleology but it doesn't possess that in
and of itself so any old enemy says its
processes is the specific activity in
which it's being for self its specific
gravity is suspended but this itself in
which in which its cohesion would exist
in is true notion and a specific
quantity but specific remedy our notions
notice he uses notions there in the
plural completely indifferent towards
each other that means did a certain
respect they're not really notions in
any full sense there's no integration
going on so then he goes on he says if
the way in which they react to each
other is left out an account and
attention is confined just to the idea
of quantity we do perhaps think of the
determination like this that a greater
specific weight as a more intensive
being within itself would resist
involvement in the process more the
smaller specific weight so greater
cohesion right maybe there's a
correlation between this number and a
number that we can assign there but
Hagel says this is precisely where the
being for itself rears its ugly head as
freedom or you might say as our units
there turns out to be no intrinsic
connection between specific gravity and
if we understand the specific gravity
why would we think that there's a
connection between that and cohesion
there's so many other possibilities all
these other factors that we don't get
anything remotely like law like
regularity that we're seeking there let
alone intelligibility so he goes on he
says the self preservation of the
inorganic in its relation falls outside
of its nature since the inorganic does
not contain within itself the principle
of movement or in other words because
it's being is not absolute negativity
and notion so if we're going to seek out
the meaning of this
it's not going to be provided by
analogies a observation of inorganic
being
this other aspect of the inorganic on
the other hand when considered not as
processed but as a quiescent being as
ordinary cohesion the simple sensuous
property standing over against the
liberated moment of other number of
mutually in different properties and
which like specific gravity is one of
those properties the multiplicity of
properties together then constitutes the
other aspect of cohesion in this however
as in the other properties number is the
sole determinant pneus and this not only
does not express a relation between
these properties in a transition from
one to another but is essentially just
the absence of any necessary relation
and it represents rather the abolition
of all conformity to law for it is the
expression of a determinate pneus that
is unessential this being so than a not
a series of bodies in which the
difference is expressed as a numerical
difference of their specific gravities
by no mean runs parallel to a series in
which the difference is that about the
other properties even if to facilitate
the comparison only one or some of them
are taken for as a matter of fact only
the entire bundle of properties could
constitute the other series in such a
parallel to bring this into order and
bind it into all observation has in its
disposal on the one hand the
quantitative determinate nas's of these
various properties on the other hand
however their differences are manifest
as qualitative now in this heap of
properties what would he have to be
characterized as positive or negative it
is mutually canceling each other in
general the internal arrangement and
Exposition the formula which would be a
very complicated matter this would be
for the notion to determine but the
notion is excluded by the very manner in
which the properties are immediately
there and taken up in his mere being of
the properties none displays the
character of a negative over against the
other on the contrary one is just as
well as the other is nor does it
indicate in any other way its place in
the arrangement of the whole in the case
of a series which progresses with
parallel differences whether the
relation is meant to be one of
simultaneous increase on both sides or
have increased
only on one and decrease on the other
what is of interest is only the final
simple expression of this combined hole
which was supposed to constitute one
aspect of the law over against specific
gravity but this one aspect is a given
result is precisely nothing else than
what has already been mentioned that is
a single property say like ordinary
cohesion alongside which the indifferent
others specific gravity among them are
found and each of the others can with
equal right that is with equal and
correctness be taken as representative
of the entire other side the one like
the other would merely represent in
German for Stalin the essential nature
but would not itself be that essential
nature so that the attempt to find
series of bodies which would run simply
parallel to each other and would express
the essential nature of the bodies
according to a law of these two series
must be regarded as a conception that is
ignorant of its task and of the means
whereby it should be carried out
in this lonely paragraph number 290 a
lot of these themes now are being
brought together and we're seeing some
you might say not not just progress
being made but some consolidation of
progress or if you like some cohesion if
we want to be able to joke here since
we've already got that on the board so
he says this other aspect of the
inorganic is ordinary cohesion right
yeah he says this is a simple sensuous
property standing over against the
liberated moment of other that's what
does he mean by that well the other
properties it stands over against these
other observable sensible properties
that are part of the the outer and he
says it's separated into a number of
mutually in different properties which
like specific which and which like
specific gravity it is one of these
products so we've got specific gravity
cohesion all these other properties like
hardness you know color and all sorts of
things that we now are treating in terms
of what we can observe what we can
measure how we can correlate them to
each other looks like we're actually
making some progress are we able to have
a law about that he goes on he reminds
us of you know why not he says the
problem the problem is that in this
number is the sole determinant pneus and
this this not only does not express the
relation between these properties and a
transition from one to the other but is
essentially just the absence of any
necessary relation and it represents
rather the abolition of any conformity
to law so because everything is
essentially reducible or reduced here to
the to the numerical we don't get the
kind of necessity that law is supposed
to bring we get a lot of information and
we get a lot of correlations between
things but we don't get any sort of
intelligibility running through all of
that that would be what Hagel calls the
notion you notice I've got the notion
cross lot crossed out down here and
we'll see why in just a moment so he
goes on
and I'm going to skip through a bit of
this because a lot of it is sort of
rehearsing what we've had already so he
says this being so now perhaps a series
of bombings in which the difference is
expressed as a numerical difference
other specific gravities by no means
runs parallel to a series in which the
difference is that of the other
properties so you're suggesting that the
whole point of talking in terms of
specific gravity as the number of the
kind of thing is not as going to be lost
so what is he tracking it back here
saying we actually don't get a series
like this but let's do is sort of a
thought experiment and assume that we
actually could correlate these things to
each other a manager that we have a
whole series of numbers that correspond
to specific gravity and these are going
to be specific gravities of particular
kinds of things so we've got 88 as a
number B is a number season over DS a
number and these correspond to you know
classes of things right and then over
here we have all these multiple
properties and I ran out of numbers
fairly quickly in part because i really
only know the roman and the Greek
alphabets and if we have more alphabets
and at my disposal and I'm sure somebody
will put something in the comments here
you know I would put a Hebrew number
that maybe I so really number who knows
right doesn't matter you get the idea
these are supposed to be properties that
are that somehow correlated there's a
series here and that a series here and
there's supposed to be some sort of
connection or correlation between the
two right so he says as a matter of fact
only the entire bundle of properties
could casa toot the other series in a
parallel to bring this into order to
bind it into a whole observation has at
its disposal on the one hand the
quantitative determinists of these
various properties right so these can be
numbered these can be then arranged in a
kind of series with each
as I actually wouldn't be just a series
would be something like you know we're
doing almost something like linear
algebra here right by handle the damn
that his disposal sites think about it
this way and he says on the other hand
their differences are manifest as
qualitative now that's a problem so
insofar as the these things are being
differentiated from each other number
isn't really going to cut it for us in
what they really are they are
qualitatively distinguished from each
other not just quantitatively
distinguished from each other and
whatever solution we might try to adapt
to this would be rather as we call it ad
hoc you know we're introducing number
where number isn't completely
appropriate so it was adamant that he
says in this heap of properties what
would have to be characterized as
positive or negative it is mutually
canceling each other if we want to
reduce everything down to mathematics
right this would be for the notion to
determine right it would be the internal
arrangements of exposition of the
formula which would it be a very
complicated matter the notion would do
this but when we are engaging in this
sort of you know thought experiment
we're actually eliminating the notion
we're pushing it out he says so he says
the notion is excluded by the very
manner in which the properties are
immediately there and taken up in this
mere being of the properties non-display
as a character of a negative over
against the other they're just different
from each other they're just they are
they actually have no connection to each
other what's a letter they're given that
connection over here to the specific
gravity but in being associated in this
series like that they're they're
disconnected from each other there's no
cohesion money is at a different word
right that the notion would be bringing
and afforded so he says that so it
doesn't indicate in any other way its
place in the arrangement of the whole
we're lacking and tell
ability in the case of a series which
progresses the parallel differences
right here whether the relation is meant
to be one of simultaneous increase or
increase on one side of decrease on the
other some sort of correlation what is
of interest is only the final simple
expression of this combined hole which
was supposed to constitute whoa right
but he says this one aspect is a given
result is precisely nothing else than
what was already mentioned that is a
single property like ordinary cohesion
alongside which the indifferent others
are found and each of the others can
with equal right that is with equal in
correctness be taken as representative
of the entire other side is totally
indifferent what we put here on this
side series you could say we can
correlate everything with everything but
in the process we lose sight it well
what the hell did all of this mean what
was the significance of that you know
you see this has been an awful lot I
don't want to pick on big data but
there's people that are gonna start
fascinated with this in our own time and
they think that we got a whole array of
numbers they gotta mean something we got
to be able to draw some connection
somewhere and that's not always the case
if you don't have something like what
Hagel is calling the notion something
bringing them together and providing
them with some intelligibility with some
way of cursing the data as we say some
modes of interpretation you're going to
lose sight of what what are you doing in
the first place with all of this and so
we're trying to make sense out of things
organic beings and energetic beings
that's going to be a problem so he goes
and he says this ends up getting us back
into just merely representing it uses
this term represent here in right and
then he says in German we call that for
show and we've talked about this in
of times already when we don't have the
concept the the the notion that we could
that way of approaching things we turn
things into mirror representation and
the understanding is often very happy
with that but reason is not and remember
this section is observing reason not
just hit you understand it goes to town
so he goes already says the attempt to
find series of bodies which would run
simply parallel to each other and which
would also express the essential nature
of the bodies according to the law of
these two series must be regarded as a
conception that is ignorant of its task
and of the means whereby it should be
carried out he's saying that this way is
this mode of looking at things is sort
of a cookie cutter approach that cannot
give us what it is that we are looking
for in observing natural things